We Begin this morning with the latest on
President Joe Biden's Health the
president's longtime physician has
confirmed a lesion removed from his
chest last month was cancerous the
president's doctor declared the 80 year
old has healed nicely as we await him to
officially launching his re-election
campaign Christina raffini is at the
White House with the latest Christina
good morning
good morning Dana will about three and a
half million Americans receive a skin
cancer diagnosis each year of course
only one of them is president
in a memo released late yesterday the
president's doctor said a lesion removed
from Mr Biden's chest during an exam
last month tested positive for basal
cell carcinoma a type of skin cancer
adding that all cancerous tissue was
successfully removed and that no further
treatment is required basal cell
carcinomas don't invade but they
classically grow and they can cause
local problems hence the need to remove
them CBS News medical contributor Dr
David agus says the president will
require regular monitoring for new
lesions when there's some it means there
probably will be more and it represents
skin damage during his life the 80 year
old president's age and health have been
a constant part of the conversation
about his anticipated though still yet
not confirmed re-election run when will
you announce your re-election sir
CBS News has confirmed the Biden
reelection team is working to put
together an Advisory Board of
high-profile Democrats to help unify the
party after months of polling showing
Democratic voters reluctance or concern
for a second Biden campaign given his
age potential 2024 Republican contenders
are already making the president's age
an issue on 51 that's younger than Don
Lemon
it's also younger than Hunter Biden and
it's 30 years younger than Joe Biden
former South Carolina Governor Nikki
Haley kicked off her run calling for
competency tests for leaders over the
age of 75. in the America I see the
permanent politician will finally retire
but former vice president Mike Pence
also likely to run told CBS News
Americans can make that decision for
themselves my problems with President
binaural the failed policies at home and
abroad
now this type of cancer is quite common
in fact first lady Jill Biden had the
same type of lesions removed traveling
overseas last week she was asked if she
thought her pres her husband should run
again for president she said I'm all for
it guys
something many many people have dealt
with Christina thank you very much